trucker virus coverage here at noon and
long lines again today at the las vegas
convention center
as people arrive there to get their
second dose madison kimbrough is there
live and madison you're hearing they
actually cut the line off
yeah so they did just earlier and i'm
going to show you kind of where this
line is happening as you can see it is
still very significant
i am told that they are not accepting
any more walk-ups that ended about an
hour ago however
these lines are causing frustrations for
those who showed up
and not only are those lines long
outside but inside
too we're getting a lot of complaints
into our newsroom about the process
i've reached out to the county and the
health district to get some
clarification
on why these lines have been so long and
what's being done i'm waiting to hear
back
in the meantime i spoke to this man who
has been waiting patiently for his
second dose
i've been here probably 30 minutes it
looks like it's going to be at least
another hour hour and a half i'm happy
to get it i'm happy to get the second
shot now this location opened to watkins
last week for those who had their first
dose of the moderna vaccine
but could not schedule an appointment
for the second dose online
then it was announced that this week
walk-ins were available for the pfizer
vaccine so again we want to tell you
that if you were planning to come here
as a walk-up for the second dose do not
come they are not accepting any more
people
without an appointment and again i have
reached out to the health district and
the county
to see the reasoning for these long
lines and why it is taking so long
reporting live from the las vegas
convention center madison kimbrough 8
news now
all right well we hope to get some
answers thank you so much madison